but i got a special fan for you how's
kevin hart for you no he needs he need a
ladder
not one of the best oh i like it how'd
you feel when brady had that ball and
got sacked look at my eye lost the ball
i'll say this
look at my eyes we're very lucky to have
this guy
a part of this team
i've been drinking
[Laughter]
i'm on cloud9
that's important you were so [ __ ] up
yeah yeah he was trying to be
professional that's the part i'm trying
to love you okay
i am on tv but look let me tell y'all
look have you ever had that have you
ever been so
so messed up like that you you tried to
keep it together but while you're trying
to keep it together in your mind you
like i look stupid as [ __ ] right now i
definitely did that when the lakers hit
the uh they hit the portland
trailblazers in their game seven
and me and the homies just busted in the
locker room at the end of the game and
they was doing an interview with jim
here we was like we don't give a [ __ ]
what's happening [ __ ] the mic is war
[ __ ]